more than 11 million people around the
globe are visually impaired or blind as
a result of a condition called
age-related macular degeneration or amd
as the world population ages this number
is projected to rise to over 18 million
people by the year 2040
advanced amd comes in two forms wet and
dry and it's not clear why people
develop one type instead of another
without treatment both types can
ultimately lead to blindness
so what happens in the eye to cause this
loss of vision
in a healthy retina rods and cones your
photoreceptors translate light from the
outside world into electrical signals to
send to the brain
these rods and cones sit on the retinal
pigment epithelium or rpe
beneath that is brook's membrane which
regulates the flow of nutrients and
waste products between the epithelium
and the underlying blood vessels
this is one of the places amd most
likely begins in the collection of small
blood vessels called the coriocalaris
as our eyes age these blood vessels
become more sparse this begins to happen
much more quickly in people with dry amd
next deposits of lipids proteins and
minerals called drusen start to form
within brook's membrane and as the
disease progresses these deposits grow
and block nutrients which were headed
for the rpe
the drusen also prevent waste products
from being moved away
without good nutrient supply and with
toxins building up the rpe degrades
to make matters worse drusen contain
proteins that can activate immune cells
causing an inflammatory response
heightened inflammation contributes to
more blood vessel loss and that in turn
starves the rpe further
and as a result starves the
photoreceptors of vital nutrients
as dry amd progresses cells begin to
detach from brook's membrane
this leads to blindness
there is no cure for dry amd at the
moment but a good number of treatments
are currently being trialled
dead photoreceptors can't be replaced
but a type of cell therapy aims to
repopulate lost rpe cells and keep
whatever photoreceptors do remain
healthier for longer
to do that healthy rpe cells grown from
stem cells are either injected into the
retina or embedded in a brook like
membrane which can then be implanted
these new rpe cells help to preserve any
remaining photoreceptors and can hold
back the tide of destruction that amd
causes
other treatments aim to prevent the
worst of the damage before it even
occurs
some of these aim to reduce build-up of
toxic waste products or to make the
photoreceptors more resilient better
able to hold on tightly in the face of
degradation of rpe cells
or they aim to interfere with the
protein pathway that revs up the
inflammatory response
none of these therapeutic approaches
have been through all the required
stages of clinical trials to become
widely available to patients but any one
of them or perhaps a combination of
several could prove to be life-changing
for people around the globe with dry amd